the first 100 Grand was the richest I
have ever felt to this day I remember
pulling up our bank account and there's
100 Grand in it hey babe like check this
out and I just like showed it to her cuz
I was getting choked up and right after
I said that I was like bab I was like we
can up for 3 years and be okay for
anyone who's broke right now you
probably know what your burn rate is and
I was like 30 grand a year I was like
both of us together we're good can't
lose now I was like we got 3 years to
Runway I think about that a lot cuz I'm
like I wonder why why did I feel so rich
in that moment and I think it's because
the Rel change in wealth was so extreme
if you have $1,000 in make and you go to
$100,000 you're hundred times richer I
mean for everyone who's listening like I
was broke up to this point I get it like
it was insane